[Music]
hello and welcome to the first look at
total war three kingdoms today we're
going to be playing through a single
battle it's $1.99 seee and the events of
the Three Kingdoms era are well underway
the tyrant dong zhuo is long dead
murdered by his adoptive son Liu boo
he's one of the greatest warriors of the
period who is now threatening to combine
his strength with one shoe and overwhelm
all opposition however lubu sits in CRP
isolated from his would be a lie the
legendary commander sau sau senses an
opportunity to strike lubu down before
his strength becomes too great
after months of long siege warfare and
with the defenders starved of resources
sow sow now senses the time is right
here behind the walls of CRP lubu stands
in the center preparing to fight against
the approaching march of sow sow here we
are in the battlefield the final assault
is about to begin
we have sow sow the legendary commander
leading his men into battle we're going
for a two-pronged approach sau sau shall
lead his forces through the breach while
he Jin will March his forces to the
gatehouse and smash through and take the
main concourse but before we move
forwards we need to lay the groundwork
for our assault we're going to raise
their walls to the ground
with that underway we're going to move
our heavy spear guard up towards the
front gate for the attack on the wall
let's take a look at these heavy spear
guard they're currently in the turtle
formation using their tall shields
together with the flag bearers in the
center to protect from missile fire
which will greatly aid us in this
assault lubu is holding his position in
the center of CRP waiting for someone
worthy enough to fight in Three Kingdoms
there are unique items which can be
given to your generals here we see Liu
boos horse and weapon are unique to him
but should he be slain he could loot his
items and keep them for yourself here we
have one of our generals under Samsung
different generals can recruit different
kinds of units these two are leading
their forces together
Yujin is a guardian type hero our combat
master who excels in the heart of battle
tanking and soaking up damage while our
strategist is not great in a fight he is
incredibly useful 2d buffing enemy units
and allows us access to unique formation
types the gap on the left is now wide
enough for us to make our great assault
on the settlement sau sau and his rescue
are going to move up sau sau himself is
a commander and they excel at buffing up
nearby Allied troops rather than waiting
into combat themselves so we won't be
seeing him being the first through the
breach he's too valuable for that we
will instead be pushing up the yellow
dragons they are being supported by the
azure dragons a hybrid heavy spear and
missile infantry unit they will first
hold back and fire over the walls with
their bows and once they've spent all
their ammunition they will join in on
the frontline
let's move our heavy Spears forward to
climb the walls
[Music]
now is the time to press the attack
getting the azure dragons firing and now
charging forward to the yellow dragon
yes there are heart beating and that
spiders body is there a brain inside
that cavernous head these heavy hitting
axe units are a formidable foe for
anyone they go up against
they will make very short ones new spear
let's check up on the center attack the
settlement is now on fire from the
barrage of arrows and our men are
getting over the walls and getting stuck
into the enemy
yes
[Applause]
cousin we talk to a Jew we ride with the
orea tongue back our reinforcements have
arrived this huge massive cavalry will
be the perfect thing to break booze men
will charge them into this spear
infantry they're gonna knock these guys
fly and destroy them on our
reinforcements are led by Jay how done
he was shot in the eye by an arrow in
battle against lubu he pulled it out his
eyes still attached to the arrow and
proceeded to eat it and we're gonna get
him out of the fight and head over to
Lou boo hoo again challenged to a duel
jewels are a new feature for three
kingdoms where the two heroes will Duke
it out in single combat til one either
dies or retreat Jules can help you
single out an enemy combatant and take
them out and turn the tide of battle
this battle is heating up to see who
wins stay tuned for all of our coverage
coming out of III next week or join us
on the show floor itself for the full
experience
[Music]